[SOUND EFFECTS]
PROFESSOR: OK, I just want to
just highlight your attention
to things.
Like every day, I get
that MIT news feed.
I get a couple of
other news feeds.
And I just thought this was
really sort of a striking image
and I think a great way to
convey science and engineering
is through sort of really
eye catching imagery.
This is a synapse, which
is where nerves contact
to other nerves or to the
neuromuscular junction
in order to trigger activity.
And this is a piece of research
out of the Cima-- whoops,
go back one-- whoops,
go back one more--
between the Cima
and Langer labs,
where they've designed
little tiny microchip probes.
They're about 10 microns big.
They can be planted in the
brain in different sites,
hopefully non-invasively.
And they can report
on concentrations
of this neurotransmitter,
dopamine.
And the reason you might
want to be able to do that
is that there is a
dopamine deficit in a lot
of neurologic disorders.
So you would like to understand
what the deficits are
and pinpoint points of the
brain where there may be issues.
And in fact, they used it to
track Parkinson's disease.
Because Parkinson's
disease, some
of the therapeutic approaches
involve deep brain stimulation.
But you can't
really tell if it's
working unless you
can measure something.
And the thing that
you could measure
would be the absolute levels
of this neurotransmitter,
dopamine, which, by the way, is
originated from the amino acid
tyrosine.
You could sort of spot
some of the parts of that.
That would be the carbon.
Becomes a c-- there's a
carboxylate and an amine.
Oh, I've drawn the alcohol.
This should be an NH2.
Sorry, I just added
this at last minute.
So dopamine actually though
originates from tyrosine.
So I just thought you would
be interested because when
I talk about the highlighting
things that are in the news,
I mean things like this where
we're all kind of interested.
It's cool.
It's relevant to what we do.
And it really
combines the efforts
of scientists and engineers
to make tools and methods
and invent methods
to make measurements
that are quantitative
enough to guide
the analysis of a disorder.
So I just want to wrap up a
little bit on the aspects.
I was showing you the energy
diagrams in the last class
and telling you how enzymes
affect the course of a reaction
by lowering the
energy of activation,
by stabilizing a transition
state or a high energy
intermediate state.
So the energy of
activation becomes
smaller in the
catalyzed reaction,
therefore faster than
any uncatalyzed reaction.
And I did not give you
this number last time.
Enzymes catalyze
reactions through about 10
to the 6, a million
10 to the 10-fold.
So these are dramatic
increases in rates
that are really physio-- we
depend on physiologically.
They ensure specificity.
And they're essential
in all systems.
And the way we discuss energetic
changes in reaction diagrams
is by looking at what's
known as the delta
G. It's the change
in free energy.
What I show you here is an
exergonic reaction, where
it is a negative delta G. I
didn't reinforce that point
enough last time.
The energy of the products
is lower than the energy
of the substrates.
So energy is given out at the
end of the transformation.
That means the reaction
is favorable with respect
to an equilibrium, a
thermodynamic parameter.
And then it's the
enzyme that takes
care of the kinetic
aspects of the reaction.
So just to sort of
show you the correlate,
an endergonic reaction
would look like this,
where the delta G is positive.
The products are less stable
than the starting materials,
which would mean the
reaction is not favorable.
But it will still proceed in
the presence of a catalyst.
And in this next
small bit where we
talk about pathways
and different aspects
of metabolism, I'm
going to tell you
how we get around the
unfavorable equilibrium
problem.
Because that's obviously a big
predicament in biochemistry.
If reactions aren't
favorable, why
do they go far enough to be
useful to us in metabolism?
So that reaction would
have a positive delta G.
And then I also mentioned
these two terms.
Anabolic refers to the
endergonic reactions.
I don't know why you're
doing this to me--
the endergonic reactions.
And catabolic refers to
the exergonic reactions.
OK, then this last point--
I showed you this
slide last time.
But I think it was
important to think about,
why are enzymes so big?
And I want to give one example
of an additional genetic
mutation that causes a human
disorder, where I at least show
you how the mutations
are spread quite
a distance from
the reaction center
to show you that all of
that structure that you see
in an enzyme as it interacts
with a small substrate
is critical for catalysis.
So we see small
substrates in each case.
But we have this
very large enzyme,
which is many, many times its
size, all engaged in catalysis.
But what's the proof of that?
So why are enzymes so big?
So phenylketonuria
is a human disorder.
It's one of those
disorders that neonates,
brand newborns are tested for.
They are checked for
the genetic signal
that shows that the
protein will have
mutations in its structure.
And there are many mutations
associated with a defect
in this particular protein.
And the protein that
I'm talking about
is phenylalanine hydroxylase.
So the disorder is
related to defects
in phenylalanine hydroxylase.
Now what does that enzyme do?
It takes phenylalanine and
installs a hydroxyl group
opposite to where it's
attached to the amino acid.
So this is the hydrophobic
amino acid phenylalanine.
And this is another one of
the hydrophobic amino acids
in a similar family
that's tyrosine.
And in fact, it's the precursor
to dopamine physiologically.
Now it turns out
there can always
be too much of a good thing.
So if you have too
much phenylalanine,
it has to be converted to
a different amino acid.
Because the build
up of phenylalanine
gets to a certain stage
where it is converted itself
to a toxic byproduct
that actually
causes severe mental
disorders and seizures.
So the body needs to monitor
the levels of phenylalanine.
And at a certain stage,
phenylalanine hydroxylase
will convert it to tyrosine.
So even though
phenylalanine is essential,
too much phenylalanine
is a bad thing.
So that enzyme is the one that
is associated with defects--
with mutations.
The lower the activity of
the phenylalanine hydroxylase
and end you up accumulating
phenylalanine too high.
And so the PAH
regulates the clearance
from the body converting
it to tyrosine.
So why-- you know, I told you
I would give you some insight
into how entire enzymes are in
fact critical for cat lysis.
So what I'm showing you
on this a little movie is
that the sites shown in magenta
all around this protein,
the active site would be
where this big ball is.
It's actually cofactor iron.
But the sites that are involved
in the reduction of activity
of phenylalanine hydroxylase
are way out on the protein,
out on its perimeters.
So this protein is
about 49 angstroms,
4.9 nanometers across.
But the sites that cause
a reduction in activity
are a long way away,
10 angstroms longer,
15 angstroms, 16.
So it turns out that
enzymes as catalysts
don't just use the local
environment right near where
chemistry happens.
The entire protein collaborates
to make the changes happen
in catalysis.
So enzymes are big,
because you're not just
using this inner shell
of functional groups
where the substrate binds.
You're actually using a lot
of the dynamics of the enzyme
to promote catalysis.
And just this sort
of visual shows you
how far away things
can be where they
suppress the
activity of a protein
and make it a poorer catalyst.
OK.
So as I said, this is
one of the disorders,
the genetic mutations that
is tested for at birth.
If you have one of
these set of mutations,
you immediately have to
be put on a diet that's
low in phenylalanine, so
you don't bombard your body
with too much phenylalanine,
not allowing the phenylalanine
to build up too much.
But I don't know if
any of you have lately
grabbed a can of
Coca-Cola that's
got aspartame as a sweetener.
It turns out that sweetener,
NutraSweet rather,
is a dipeptide.
See?
But it contains phenylalanine.
So if you drink a ton of diet
drinks that include NutraSweet,
you are actually
bombing yourself
with high levels
of phenylalanine
that the body can't deal with.
So people who have
phenylketonuria,
i.e. a defect in that enzyme,
shouldn't be drinking or using
NutraSweet type sweeteners.
Because they actually
give you too much
phenylalanine at once, that
you can mitigate the levels of.
So I want to just tell you
about these genetic disorders.
There's a fairly decent set
that are tested for at birth.
But the ones that are
tested are for ones
that you can make dietary
modifications or lifestyle
modifications and
mitigate the symptoms.
And so that's a very
important thing to know.
You're not tested for things
you don't know how to fix,
because that wouldn't
be appropriate.
All right, any
questions about that?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you know, that
was me being clunky with--
of course you guys
notice everything.
This morning, I was making--
all right, let's go forward.
One, two, and that and that.
I know exactly what
you're talking about.
This little curb
down, yeah that's
me shaking when I'm doing
the ChemDraw drawing.
It should be flat.
But thank you for noticing that.
Just so that's not ambiguity,
there should not be-- there
could be, actually, a little
dip when substrates bind
to enzymes.
But I didn't mean to imply it.
OK, anything else?
OK, so what I want to talk about
now is the equilibrium problem.
And what is that?
So if we have reactions
that are endergonic--
so we have one of
these situations
where we have a substrate
going to a product that's
higher energy.
What that means is, at
equilibrium between substrate
and product, which is
defined by the delta G,
you have substrate
going to product.
But mostly, you've
got a lot of substrate
there, which is
the amount of each
of these is defined by
this energy difference.
OK.
So how do we survive with
these kinds of transformations
when we really want
the flux for an enzyme
to be in the forward direction?
Because if we need the product,
we need to move things forward.
So nature deals with this
by coupling reactions
to other reactions.
So it finds ways around
the equilibrium problem
by, for example, putting
a series of reactions.
For example, let's
go from A to B to C.
So these are three intermediates
catalyzed by enzyme 1,
enzyme 2.
OK.
And let's just say this
has an unfavorable delta G.
So we don't make-- we have a
lot of A. We have very little B.
And then what happens?
How are we going
to-- and then let's
just say, for example,
this reaction is favorable.
So let's see.
The delta G here is positive.
The delta G here is negative.
So by plus VE, I mean
positive and negative.
So this is a favorable
reaction, whereas this
is an unfavorable reaction.
How does putting two
reactions adjacent
to each other happening
on the same substrate
and moving through
help that situation?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
So the answer here is that, as
you take whatever B you have
and turn it into C, A has to--
A1 has to make more B. So you
solve the equilibrium problem
in that way to a certain
extent by just opening the tap
at the other end of the series.
And nature organizes a ton
of reactions in sequential
pathways to get around
these kinds of problems.
So this is done by
coupling reactions.
And so there are
some reactions that
are highly favorable,
highly exothermic,
where you can really
sort of guarantee flux
through that enzyme.
A lot of these enzymes
are ATP dependent.
They use and burn ATP.
So you get a lot of energy out.
And they drive the flux
through enzyme one,
by enzyme to being an
exergonic reaction,
while the enzyme one
is and endergonic.
So flux is guaranteed.
And a lot of pathways sort
of set up to be in this way
with this coupling
of the chemistries.
What else?
So what we find is that
enzymes, first of all,
work in pathways where they are
co-located in certain places.
They may be, for
example, co-localized
to certain organelles
in a human cell.
They may be co-localized
in the mitochondria
or in some organelle.
And we'll talk more about
organelles and mitochondria
later.
They could be co-localized
at a membrane.
And so you ensure that
the enzymes are together
by putting them
in the same place.
And then nature
also evolves ways
where the enzymes physically
interact with each other,
either covalently
or non-covalently.
So they could be
associated in the pathway
by some kind of
non-covalent interaction.
Or you may actually link enzymes
to make them single species.
So if this is enzyme one
and this is enzyme two,
here you have an enzyme
one, enzyme two single
long polypeptide chain
that has two domains.
They can't get away from
each other, because they're
joined covalently.
And they catalyze
sequential reactions.
This just doesn't happen
with just three enzymes.
It can happen with
10 enzymes or more.
So there are very clever
ways to ensure the flux
occurs through pathways.
OK.
But don't forget, all along,
that each of these enzymes
is responsible for a
single transformation.
That's important.
There's another phenomenon that
having flux through pathways
is very useful for, is to
deal with toxic intermediates.
Because that makes
it very advantageous,
again, to couple reactions.
So let's say product B is toxic.
We don't want it
hanging around much.
We don't want it released
from an enzyme to go do damage
somewhere in the cell.
So having flux through
a pathway basically
ensures the B never
gets out of the game.
It just goes straight
to enzyme two.
So that's another physical
advantage of those processes
being linked together.
And finally, the process also
ensures a very nice opportunity
to do regulation.
So here we on this
slide, I show you
this sort of mega mess
of metabolic pathways
in physiology.
That there would
be the Krebs cycle.
But all the metabolic pathways
that are all interlinked.
And many of these pathways
will be co-locali--
steps in these pathways will
be co-localized as clusters.
And so that deal tells you how
we can solve the equilibrium
problem by linking enzymes--
the flux through pathways.
And one of the best examples
is in aerobic glycolysis,
where in the early
steps, they're
not energetically favorable.
You use ATP to start
to break down glucose.
Then you get to a
certain intermediate
where it's conversion
to a smaller molecule
generates ATP with very
favorable reactions.
So glycolysis is a really
great example of this.
Now the other thing that I
just want to describe to you
is the issue of feedback.
And I've described this
here on this slide.
And so we'll talk
about it on this slide.
So if we are working
with a pathway
that goes through multiple steps
to make an end product, five
steps, three steps or whatever.
And you've made
too much of that.
You've already made a
lot of that product.
And you don't need anymore.
Nature also has in place
a regulatory mechanism
to feedback and stop
flux through the pathway.
You don't just stop
all the enzymes.
You find a way to
stop the first enzyme.
So this is a very important
paradigm in biochemistry.
And that's called
negative feedback.
So I'm showing you it here
just in a very simple cartoon
form in the isoleucine
biosynthesis pathway.
That's one of the
hydrophobic amino acids.
This is an intermediate
that is on its way
from this amino acid that
is polar but not charged,
threonine.
So threonine gets
converted to isoleucine.
We need threonine
to make isoleucine.
But once we got a
lot of isoleucine,
it binds to the very first
enzyme in the pathway and acts
as an allosteric regulator
that dampens activity.
So in this case, I
just want to point out
to you that I'm showing a very
common way we notate things.
When we are talking about
inhibiting a reaction,
we draw it like this.
We align and then align
to the so the arrow,
see which means you've
stopped the activity.
So you'll see this
again and again.
You're going to see it a
lot in signaling pathways,
because things often feedback.
So another thing that
nature ensures, in addition
to not building
up toxic products
and dealing with
equilibria, is that you
don't want a ton of enzymes
working to make something
you don't need anymore.
So you might as well
take the end product
and use it to stop
the first enzyme.
As that in product
becomes scarce,
it dissociates from
the first enzyme.
And it turns the
pathway back on again.
And I think that's a really
neat way of making that happen.
And also, in these
cases, the enzymes
have to be clustered as a group.
Because you wouldn't get
those local concentrations
to be so advantageous if the
enzymes weren't co-localized.
So does that make sense?
If they weren't in a really
near location, the enzyme that
present produces
isoleucine, that isoleucine
couldn't bind back to the
first enzyme in the pathway
if they were in different
compartments of the cell.
OK, everyone good with that?
Good.
All right.
OK, so now we are moving
on to carbohydrates.
It's a pretty strange
word, carbohydrate.
But actually, it relates
to early findings
that glucose is a carbohydrate.
And its molecular
formula is C6H12O6.
So they called it
a hydrate of carbon
before when they knew the
elemental composition but they
didn't know anything
about the structure.
There's a lot of carbohydrates
that don't obey this rule.
But that's where the name comes
from, a hydrate of carbon.
All right now
carbohydrates account
for-- what did I have here?
25% of the mass of
macromolecules, so
a good amount.
They are very, very
important, carbohydrates
in central metabolism.
We use carbohydrates
as a source of energy.
But also, carbohydrates
are a part
of storage of energy in the
form of polymeric structures,
that I'll describe to you.
There are different ones
in plants and in humans.
One is glycogen.
One is cellulose.
But carbohydrates have an
increasingly important role
in the extracellular matrix
in these polymers that
are wrapped around your cells
and also as signaling entities
both inside and
outside the cell.
So we used to think
of carbohydrates
and straight away connect
this with metabolism.
But the story is far
greater than that.
And I'll try to
explain to you why.
And it's because of the
richness of functional groups
in a carbohydrate.
So the simplest carbohydrate,
before I go up there,
is a three carbon molecule.
This would actually be
called glyceraldehyde.
But don't worry about
that other name for it.
It's a three carbon
carbohydrate.
And this molecule would
be called a triose.
So we've got a couple
of new-- a new suffix.
Because anything that
is a carbohydrate
ends with the suffix
"ose," not to be
confused with the suffix
"ase," which is an enzyme.
So look carefully whether it's
an "a" or "o," because it's
the difference between a
big protein that catalyzes
a reaction and a carbohydrate.
So a triose would
be a carbohydrate
with three carbons.
They have an aldehyde.
Or let's just say they have
a carbonyl functionality.
So remember, there would be lone
pair electrons on those OHs,
similarly on these.
And remember, that
each of these vertices
corresponds to a carbon.
It's some-- the way you
recognize carbohydrates is most
commonly--
is that they are rich
in carbon dash OH
bonds, which are hydroxyls.
Which makes them
polar molecules,
likely to be highly solvated
in water and very different
for from the compounds that
are rich in just CH bonds that
don't have such opportunities.
So if you see a molecule
and it's got a bunch of CHs
but not a bunch of OHs,
it's probably a lipid.
If you see a compound
that's rich in OHs,
it's likely to be
a carbohydrate.
The story gets a little
bit more interesting
as we move up to some of the
different carbohydrates, which
I've shown you there
on that screen.
And I'm going to go forward
to talk about those.
Because this triose is
important in primary metabolism.
We break down
carbon carbohydrates
that have six sugars to small
carbohydrates that have three--
excuse me,
carbohydrates that have
six carbons to carbohydrates
that have three carbons.
And that's where these three
carbon entities crop up.
But I want to focus you in
on two sets of carbohydrates,
the hexoses and the pentoses.
So we immediately know
they're carbohydrates, right?
"Ose."
The hexoses obviously
have six carbons.
And the pentoses
have five carbons.
And these are the most
important of the carbohydrates.
Yes, there are carbohydrates
with four carbons.
And then there were ones with
seven, eight, nine carbons.
But these are the
ones will totally
focus on in 7016,
because these are
very important in
different biopolymers.
And the hexoses are important
components, for example,
of cellulose and glycogen. But
where are the pentose carbons?
And why are they so important?
Actually, I need to draw this
is its straight chain version.
Because I'll drive you crazy.
So this sugar here is a
pentose, one, two, three, four,
five carbons, a bunch of
OHs, aldehyde at one end.
Commonly, carbohydrates will
fold up into a cyclic structure
through an equilibrium.
I won't worry you too
much with the chemistry.
But I'm just going to
show you that structure.
It looks like this,
a five-membered ring.
The interconversion of these
two is an equilibrium process.
And those carbohydrates are
incredibly important where?
Yeah, nucleic acids.
So your phosphodiester
backbone is
attached to sugars that are
attached a bit to purines
and pyrimidines.
And we'll see those
structures later.
But an absolutely essential
feature of that polymer
is the five-membered
ring carbohydrates
that are known as ribose,
which is what that guy is,
and two deoxyribose,
where one of the hydroxyls
is actually a hydrogen.
It's not a hydroxyl.
And it's this one.
So instead of being
an OH, it's an H.
And we number carbohydrates.
And I'll reinforce
this much more
when we talk about carbohydrate,
about nucleic acids.
There's a numbering system.
So two deoxyribose
is in your DNA.
And ribose itself
is in your RNA.
OK, so obviously, we need
to worry about carbohydrates
and learn a little
bit about them
based on that key criterion.
OK, let's move now
to the hexoses.
I'm not going to make you keep
drawing hexoses and things.
I'm going to just tell you
a little bit about them
with respect to
their structures.
So I've shown you on the board
the cyclic form of a pentose.
This is the linear form
and the cyclic form.
Let me write that down.
And by the way, in your DNA,
it's always in the cyclic form.
It's not in the linear form.
And the hexoses also have
a linear and a cyclic form.
And I show you that
equilibrium for glucose.
You see six carbons.
I've got them numbered.
And they form favorably
into the six-membered ring.
This is the cyclic
form of glucose.
This is the linear
When glucose associates
into polymers,
it becomes these things
like cellulose or glycogen.
And it depends a lot on the
linkages in those polymers
to define which one it is.
Now, as I mentioned,
carbohydrates aren't always
just a series of OH groups.
There's sometimes
other functionality.
So I'm just going to
quickly draw those.
And if you've got
them on your handouts,
you can play along with me here.
So sometimes,
there's an NH2 there.
That's called glucose
amine, very creatively.
Sometimes that NH2 is
converted to an amide,
like that bond in a peptide.
So it's glucose amide.
And sometimes-- so you can
draw these on your handout,
because the six-membered
rings are there.
This stays as an OH.
But this OH here is at a
different oxidation state.
Don't worry about
that terminology.
But what's important,
it's glucuronic acid.
So it can be negatively charged,
positively charged, neutral.
So there are variations
on a lot of our hexoses,
basically meaning this
carbohydrate molecular formula
doesn't work anymore.
But the term has stuck.
So there's quite a variety
of different carbohydrates
with slight differences.
And the intriguing thing
is that the carbohydrates
that you and I use in all
of our physiologic processes
are much simpler than
the carbohydrates
that bacteria use.
There is an expansion of
like 10 to the 2 or 10
to the 3 in the variety of
sugars that bacteria use.
And that's definitely a
story for another day.
So let me now move on to
thinking about carbohydrates
not as the monomers
that you metabolize,
but rather as the
polymers that are
involved in many other
different types of processes.
And when we think
about the polymers,
we want to think about
how their polymers differ
from the polymers of
nucleic acids or proteins.
Because this will tell
you why carbohydrates
are so complicated.
When you take a bunch of amino
acids and make a polymer,
it's a linear polymer.
Every unit is joined
to the next by a name.
There's no branching there.
It's just a linear polymer.
So the diversity
is not enormous.
Or-- it's pretty enormous.
But it's not as
big as it could be
if it were a branch polymer with
different types of side chains.
We will see next week that the
polymers of the nucleic acids--
here's the basic structure.
There's the ribose, by the way.
The R could be an OH or an H
attached to a base of purine
or pyrimidine-- you don't
need to know that yet;
you'll know it next week--
and then to a phosphate.
But those again,
are linear polymers.
You don't have branching.
You just have a single
continuous chain.
The crazy thing about
sugars is they can
branch from any of those OHs.
So there's much more diversity
of structure and function
wrapped in the
carbohydrates, which makes
them real trouble to study.
OK, I want to now introduce
you to another feature.
The other thing is,
when we join amino acids
or we join nucleic acid
building blocks, nucleosides,
there's no difference in
the shapes that we can form.
We don't have variety there.
But in sugars, we can make
different kinds of linkages
depending on how two OH
groups in a sugar are joined.
So for example, if
you join two glucoses,
in this kind of linkage,
that would give you maltose.
But if you join two glucoses
in that kind of linkage,
it would give you lactose.
And those are
different compounds.
They serve different types
of physiologic roles.
And there are enzymes that
will make these bonds and then
enzymes that will
break these bonds.
There is a common disorder that
people have as they grow older.
The enzyme that breaks
the lactose bond the gets
turned off.
It doesn't work anymore.
And that's the enzyme, lactose.
So when people are
intolerant to sugars--
lactose is the sugar in milk.
And they can't digest
dairy products.
Because lactase
doesn't work anymore.
Or you can take supplements.
So that's how that
relates to physiology.
The reaction
between two glucoses
to make the disaccharide
is actually a condensation.
Because when you join
that bond, you kick out
water as a side product.
Or when you break that
bond, you release water.
So this is another one of
the condensation reactions.
So underline that on the slide.
Because condensation
means a reaction
that precedes and produces
you a molecule of water.
And this just sums up
the lactase problem,
where you can digest
lactose, the milk sugar.
OK, so those are monomers.
Now let's think about polymers
and complex structures
of sugars.
And I put these
all on the slides,
because it's just impossible
for you to keep drawing them.
And I'm just going to give you
sort of one of my pet peeves.
I draw sugars like this.
A lot of other people
draw sugars like that.
And I don't like that.
Because this is
what they look like.
So if you see this
and you go, I haven't
seen sugars looking
like that before, it's
because this is the way to draw
them that actually represents
their shape.
So if it's unusual
format to you,
I'm not going to ask
you to construct these.
I just want you to be familiar
with looking at them like this
rather than like this.
Because, to me, that's the
best way to render them.
OK, so polymers of sugar.
I just mentioned
to you, there are
polymers of sugars that
are important to storage.
So when we have
excess glucose, we
store glucose as glycogen.
It's often stored in the liver.
And later on in
the semester, we'll
see how a bolt of
adrenaline sets
all the processes in
motion to chew up glycogen,
to release more glucose so
you can have a lot of energy
quickly.
So in that polymer, the sugars
are linked in a different way.
The common polymer in
plants and, in fact,
accounts for a massive
proportion of the biomass,
is a different
polymer of glucose
where the linkages are beta--
we would call this
a beta linkage.
But that's the way it looks.
And that would be cellulose.
And it's a linear polymer.
Coming down here, glycogen
is often a branched polymer
with different kinds of
linkages with different aspects
or different shapes.
So the glycogen that we
store and can break down
in order to produce glucose
to make energy is glycogen.
We cannot break down cellulose.
We don't digest plant
cellulose, because we
don't have those
enzymes, which is
why we don't get
nutritional value out
of the cellulose the same way
we can put forces in action
to break down glucose.
So the way those bonds look
is absolutely critical for how
you can use the energy that's
within them by using enzymes
to break those bonds.
OK, so in general--
I've just said that.
Glucose can be stored a
cellulose or as glycogen.
The process of photosynthesis
converts energy and sunlight
into glucose.
And then you can make
the polymers of glucose.
And what I'm showing you
here in these polymers
is a simplified view.
I want to introduce
to you one other term.
And that term is glycan.
And that basically
refers to something
that is more than one
sugar, one carbohydrate.
I was looking at the
videos of my lectures.
I realized my
handwriting is horrible.
So I'm really trying very
hard to make it a little bit
neater today.
So glycan is just the name
for a polymer of sugars.
But they can also be
called polysaccharides.
But glycan now is the
commonly accepted term
for a lot of sugars.
Now, I told you
about energy storage.
I've told you about
simple disaccharides
and monosaccharides
and metabolism.
But what I want to
do now is give you
a little overview of all
the different places where
sugars feature in a cell.
Because I think it's
really important
to realize that sugars
form a great sort of set
of molecules for communication.
So I'm going to go
around this sort
of funny looking square cell.
And this would be
a eukaryotic cell,
because it's got a nucleus.
And there are
different compartments.
So within the
cell, the cell sits
in what's known as an
extracellular matrix.
It's a mesh work
of sugar polymers
that actually is
important for the cells
and important for trapping
signals that come from cells
and go to other cells.
So those are all predominantly
made up of carbohydrate.
The next thing to
look at is that there
are proteins within the cell.
They can become modified with
a sugar and go to the nucleus
or leave the nucleus.
So there is a type of signaling
that is based on adding a sugar
or taking it off a protein.
We'll see later in the semester
how also phosphorylation
does a lot of functions
that look like that.
There are sugars that are
displayed on the cell surface
polymers.
And that's where signaling
becomes important.
Because sugars may be
attached to lipids.
You remember, we've
talked about phospholipids
being part of the membrane.
Sugars can be attached to
lipids that sit in the membrane
and face out.
And it's how cell-cell
communication
occurs in some instances.
Or they may be
attached to proteins
that are also displayed on
the surface of the cell.
So this tells you a
little bit about where
we put these sugars is what's
responsible for communication.
Because they're on the surface
of the cell with their sides
out.
And then the final thing
I want to talk about
is the blood group system.
So a lot of you may be
aware of blood groups.
There are four
principal blood groups.
The differences between the
blood in a A, B, AB and O blood
groups are differences in just
the sugars that are attached
to the surface of the cell.
So let me describe those.
And then we'll talk about
blood groups and things that
are being done to enhance the
supplies of red blood cells
in cases of emergency.
I have a nice little video
I'm hoping to get to.
So on the surface
of the cell, you
might have different sugars.
This is a trisaccharide.
All right, you can see
one, two, three sugars.
They have different linkages.
But you can pick out the sugars.
And they are joined by a
bond called a glycoside bond
and those join sugars.
So what do you think the enzyme
that cleaves the glycoside is?
STUDENT: Glycosidase.
PROFESSOR: Glycosidase.
You would say glycosidase.
I would say glycosidase.
But if they are the same thing.
And that's going to be
pertinent in a minute.
So remember, if in doubt,
guess and stick "ase"
at the end if I ask you
the name of an enzyme,
because that works pretty well.
So if you have O
blood group, you
would have exclusively this
trisaccharide on your red blood
cells.
If you have the A
blood group, you
have an extra sugar attached
to that trisaccharide.
And it's a glucosamide sugar.
There's an extra carbonyl
group on an amide.
And if you have B blood
group, it's gluco--
it's a sugar.
It's actually called galactose.
That has all OH groups.
So the differences
between if you're O group,
if you're A group,
or if you're B group,
adjust those
differences in sugars.
And then people who have AB
blood group have a composite.
They have a mixture of the
A and the B blood group.
So do you-- yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
a second marker,
which we won't talk about.
So it's A plus another
marker that's either
one type or another type.
But the AB and O are
defined by the sugars.
Yeah, good question.
OK, so do people know
their blood group?
It's good to know, frankly.
Because someone-- you know,
you may you cut yourself.
And someone says, do you
know your blood group?
And you'll go, yes.
And they'll give you
an on-site transfusion.
I've been watching
too much Jack Bauer.
But, you know, that's a story
for another day as well.
So it turns out that
depending on blood groups,
you can either be a universal
donor or a universal acceptor.
So the people with
the O blood group
can give anyone their blood.
People with O, A, B, and AB.
But unfortunately for the poor
people with O blood group is
that they cannot receive blood
from blood group A, B, or AB.
And I wanted to show this.
And I hope I can get it working.
Because we have just the
right amount of time,
which makes me really happy.
Because I don't really program
things that well sometimes.
There was a pay-- there was--
the latest American chemist--
NARRATOR: --or other disaster.
Those who are affected
by crisis usually
need four vital things, food,
shelter, water and blood.
In particular, O-type blood,
because it can be safely given
to any patient.
Now, scientists say they
have identified enzymes
from the human gut that can turn
type A and B blood into type
O up to 30 times more
efficiently than previously
studied enzymes.
Type A or B blood
has specific sugars
on the outside of its cells.
PROFESSOR: I just described--
NARRATOR: These
sugars are recognized
by the immune system.
And if they don't
match the type of blood
that's already in an individual,
those cells are destroyed.
Because these sugars
are recognized
by the immune system,
they're called antigens.
Type AB blood has both antigens.
And type O blood has none.
The researchers
presented these findings
at the recent American
Chemical Society
National Meeting in Boston.
Stephen Withers from the
University of British Columbia
has been studying enzymes
that remove A or B
antigens from red blood cells.
If those antigens
can be removed,
then type A or B can be
converted to type O blood.
To find the enzymes
more quickly,
Withers and a colleague at his
institution used a technique
called metagenomics,
which allows scientists
to sample the genes of
millions of microorganisms
without the need
for individual c--
PROFESSOR: So that
tells you something
about technology and engineering
and understanding structures.
So it would be
really advantageous.
The stage at which you
really need blood supplies
is to take all the
blood in the blood banks
and turn everything
into a universal donor.
But the blood banks keep
these differentiated supplies
of blood.
But what if you need something
that you can give everyone
safely?
And so there are
enzymes in the gut.
There are bacteria in the
gut that actually live off
of sugars that
they chop off cells
in the matrix in the GI system.
And so what the
Withers group did
was to screen a lot
of different enzymes
from bacteria in
the gut and find
ones that had a really good
specificity for removing
those sugars.
Then they did
protein engineering
work to make them
more efficient,
thus creating something
that was proposed
a long time ago as could
be useful, but now really
making it useful.
Because those enzymes
are much more efficient.
They really catalyze
reactions at great speed.
So they're much more
efficient engineering enzymes
to treat your blood
cells, to make
sure you get rid
of all the features
that are characteristic of the
A, the B, and the AB antigens.
Because if you don't
do a good job of it,
then the human
immune system will
recognize the little
bits that sneak in
and start triggering
an immune response.
So the efficiency of the enzymes
that cleave those sugars off
is absolutely paramount.
And that's what I
have for you today.
I will see you Monday,
so don't forget.
The Pset's due at 3:00.
Monday, I would like for you
to have a preview of the--
whoops, come on-- of the
DNA reading material.
I don't know if
any of you do this.
But I think it's really handy.
So there's just some
very little sections
that will give you a bit of
exposure to nucleic acids.
It'll just make the
lecture a little bit more
kind of familiar.
But that's what
we're up for Monday.